what I hope to do in this video is give
ourselves some practice at critically
looking at how folks manipulate
polynomials and the reason why this is
useful is because it's useful to be able
to do this to yourself as you manipulate
polynomials to say wait what did I
exactly do there are a lot of times if
you're reading a math or a science book
they're going to do some proof or
something like that and say oh well you
know it's obviously from this step to
this step in you're going to try to
follow it it's like well does that make
sense
so it's a really useful muscle to be
able to see like does do these steps or
how whoever manipulated the polynomial
that doesn't make sense to you and
especially if it's you it's super useful
to be able to find if there are errors
and to correct them it'll just give you
a better critical eye for this type of
thing so let's just start with this one
we have 4x minus 3 times X minus 2
squared and it looks like this person
over five steps tries to expand it out
and so what I encourage you to pause the
video right now and see if they did it
correctly and if they didn't do it
correctly try to identify on what step
they messed up all right so assuming you
had a go at it let's do this together so
as we go from the first expression to
the second for to step one what do they
do well they just expand it out X minus
2 squared X minus 2 squared is just X
minus 2 times X minus 2 they haven't
done anything to the 4 X minus 3 yet and
I want to do in a step so that seems
correct so in step 2 they looks like
they're just trying to multiply X minus
2 times X minus 2 so you have X times X
which would be x squared you have x
times negative 2 which would be negative
2x you have negative 2 times X which
would be negative 2x and then you have
negative 2 times negative 2 which would
be positive 4 so it looks like they
multiply this out correctly so step 2
words we're still doing good all right
now what are they do in step 3 and this
whole time for X minus 3 they haven't
really touched it yet so they're just
trying to simplify it and all they did
is they added these two middle terms
minus negative 2x minus 2x it's going to
be negative 4x so this still this still
looks correct the x squared didn't
change the plus 4 didn't change they
just added these middle two terms now as
we go to this next
for well now they're trying to multiply
they're trying to multiply these two
expressions so they're doing some
algebraic multiplication so let's see if
we can figure this out
so we have 4x times let me just in a new
color I'm getting bored of that magenta
all right so we have we have 4x times x
squared which is indeed 4x to the third
power then you have 4x times negative 4x
which is going to be negative 16x
squared so they did that right then you
have 4x times 4 which is going to be 16x
and they wrote that right over there
then you're going to have negative 3
times x squared which is negative 3 x
squared we see that right over there
then you're going to have a negative 3
times negative 4x which is going to be
positive 12x and they wrote negative 12x
so they forgot they saw me they saw a
negative negative but they still put a
negative there negative 3 times negative
4x is negative x I thing is going to be
a positive positive 12x so they made an
error here and then they said negative 3
times positive 4 which is indeed
negative 12 so this part is right so the
error this thing should read positive
positive 12x
so the error they made is in step 4 step
4 is the error and then that ended up
giving them the wrong answer here
because they did a minus 12x instead of
if this was a negative 12x the negative
12x plus 16x got you this 4x but we know
it's supposed to be plus 12x so it
really should be it really should be 28
this should be 20 this should be 28 X
right over here but they really messed
up if you if you take that error they
did this step right but step 4 is where
they actually made the error so let's
keep going let's give ourselves a little
bit more practice at at looking at ways
to manipulate polynomials and see if
they're valid so here this comes from an
exercise on Khan Academy let's see which
of these are valid identities which are
which of these are valid statements so
this first one 2x plus y times 4 X 2 X
plus y times 4 X minus 2y is all of this
business right over here let's just
multiply it out 2x times 4x is going to
be 8x squared 2x times negative 2 y is
going to be negative negative 4 XY and
then let me switch colors Y times 4x is
going to be plus 4 X Y and then Y times
negative 2 y is going to be is going to
be minus 2 y squared and so let's see
these two did I do that right let's see
2x 2x times negative 2 is negative 4 X Y
and then I had 4 x times y is positive 4
X Y so these two are going to cancel out
so this is already this is looking shady
so while we're left with is 8 x squared
minus 2y squared if we factor 2 out if
we factor 2 out it's going to be 2 times
4 x squared minus y squared so this is
this is not a true this is not a true
statement right over here now let's try
this one n plus 2 squared n plus 2
squared minus N squared is equal to this
well what's n plus 2 squared that's
going to be N squared plus plus 4n it's
going to be 2 n plus 2 n it's going to
be plus 4 n plus 4 and then we're going
to subtract out an N squared
these cancel so you're gonna have 4n
plus 4 which is equal to 4 times n plus
1 so this one right over here works out
this is a true I guess in the language
of this question it is a valid identity
or you could say it's a true statement
this equation is true and then we have
this last one right over here and once
again let's see if we can multiply it
out let me go down here into the black
space so if I have a times 2a that's
going to be 2a squared and then a times
1 is going to be plus a and then if I
have B times 2a it's going to be plus 2
a B and then finally if I have B
eight times one it's going to be plus B
and then out here and then out here we
are subtracting a B so over here we're
going to subtract to be these characters
are going to cancel out and then we're
left with two a squared plus a plus two
a B and it looks like they factored out
an a so let's see if we can factor out
an a ourselves so if we factor out an a
we're going to be left with this first
term it's going to be 2a it's going to
be 2a this right over here if we factor
out an a is going to be plus one and
this if we factor out an a is going to
be 2b is going to be 2 B and that's what
exactly what they wrote over here they
just wrote in a different order a times
2a 2a plus 2b plus 2b plus 1 plus 1 so
this is legit so hopefully that gave us
some good practice it's critically
looking at whether people are making
valid statements and this is going to be
the most useful to figure out if you are
making valid statements all right
hopefully you enjoyed that